retour en effet à Avignon ou de Lauren
Zasso en attendant Godo de Samuel bequet
c'est toute une partie de l'histoire du
théâtre et aussi une partie de
l'histoire du Festival d'Avignon qui se
trouve présenté en cette année 1979 et
en raccourci en attendant Godo ce fut il
y a quelques années un tournant
probablement dans le théâtre une pièce
révolutionnaire devenue d'ailleurs au
fil des ans pratiquement une pièce très
classique pour cette version d'Avignon
l'atelier théâtrale de Louvin laanuve a
fait appel à trois comédiens trois
acteurs hors du commun George Wilson
Michel Bouet et j'ajouterai and Burton
et and qui
avec
attention il est
méchant avec les
étrangers
qui je me
présente mais non passie je suis ce n
vous dit rien je vous demande si ce nom
ne vous dit
[Musique]
rien jeis pas
famille
auourie
vous êtes bien des êtres humains
cependant à ce que je
vois de la même espèce que
moi de la même espèce que
poo d'origine
divine c'estàd
que qui est
godoo vous m'avez pris pouro ah non
monsieur pas à se instant monsieur qui
bien une
connaissance
pasme pas pr pour
luioue
pas vous l'attendz
donc c'estàd
ici sur mes
TER
on ne pensait pas à maltait dans une
bonne intention la route est à tout le
monde c'est ce qu'on se disait c'est une
honte mais c'est ainsi on n peut rien ne
parlons plus de
çage Wilson est-ce que c'est bien le
rôle du Festival d'Avignon qui doit être
un festival de création un festival
révolutionnaire dans le bon sens du
terme si vous voulez encore qu' pas de
mauvais sens mais plutôt que de monter
en attendant Godo qui est une pièce
vraiment très très connue et où les
spectateurs viennent plus voir le numéro
d'acteur qui la pièce
non d'abord la pièce n'est pas très
connue contrairement à ce que vous vous
pensez on croit connaître la pièce on en
a un vague souvenir les gens on plus ou
moins lu l'ont vu mais mais elle étaé
joué dans dans sur toutes les scènes oui
mais elle est pas très très connu enfin
bon en tout cas là il s'agit de la jouer
dans une
dimension d'un théâtre populaire
c'est-à-dire devant 3000 personnes et on
est obligé de prendre la la chose sur
son plan de la mesurer de l' prendre sur
son plan lyrique et elle devient autre
chose parce que c'est une ça fait partie
d'Avignon c'est comme ça que les choses
deviennent plus ou moins
euh appréciable par le public mais alors
avignion transfigure les pièces oui euh
en tout cas la cour dehneur et même les
autres lieux j'ai vu hier la pièce de
d'Arian que Arian mquel a monté c'est le
même problème euh le le j'étais dans le
public et vraiment j'ai senenti que les
acteurs étaient obligés de donner
beaucoup plus de s'engager beaucoup plus
voilà je crois que
Avignon oblige l'acteur à s'engager et
s'il s'engage il ne peut le faire que
dans dans dans des conditions de de de
communicabilité avec le public voilà
Rufus vous partagez je suppose l'analyse
de George Wilson à votre eselon vous
travaillez à la fois dans le cabaret
dans le théâtre vous partagez beaucoup
d'expérience au niveau du spectacle
est-ce que l'expérience Godo vous
apporte quelque chose de particulier oui
justement l'expérience de pouvoir jouer
devant 4000 personnes une pièce réputée
de café théâtre ce qui prouve que on a
dit beaucoup de bêtises à ce sujet
jusqu'à maintenant donc tout peut se
jouer dans la cour d'honneur on peut
jouer une pièce intime devant 4000
personnes si elle est bien joué et il y
a pas des il y a pas des pièces
réservées pour une petite élite pour
trois personnes cacher quelqu quelque
part et c'est pourquoi cette pièce c'est
pourquoi c'est toujours révolutionnaire
parce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
il y a 15 ans elle était révolutionnaire
et aujourd'hui il est encore non mais je
disais elle est révolutionnaire est
toujours mais elle est devenue vraiment
tellement classique bon wilsonson dit
qu'elle n'est pas très connue elle est
quand même connue non moi qui ai fait la
la régie de cette pièce pendant
plusieurs mois puisque j'étais régisseur
au départ dans ce
métier j'ai découvert la ici et pourtant
je la voyais tous les jours bon là il y
a peut-être l'intervention d'un homme
qui est le metteur en scène aussi qui
vous a
peut-être dirigé je vois un petit signe
de négation de jege Wilson mais enfin
tout de même ça a son importance non
mais si jeange Wilson dit non non j'ai
pas dit non j'ai pas dit non je veux pas
ôter non non TR c'est plus le cadre
finalement non c'est pas le travail le
travail de otomar KKA vous savez il faut
mettre une pièce en œuvre d'abord il
faut la mettre en œuvre pour que le
public la reçoive bon ça c'est c'est
c'est primordial I ici on est obligé
c'est comme on est obligé de passer au
laminoir ici et je pense pas que les
metteurs en scène qui sont là me disent
le contraire et c'est en passant au la
minoire que bon la pièce prend son
essort il lui pousse des ailes voilà ce
que je veux dire le M j'enlève rien au
mur en scène étant donné que moi je suis
mur en scène ici je l'ai fait pendant
des années je sais ce que ça veut dire
mais ça n'est pas la mise en scène pure
qui qui sauve un spectacle c'est pas
vrai il faut que les gens s'engage ici
nous avons un personnage